look journalists always have personal
points of view i mean you can't be
100 neutral ever and even aspiring to be
is almost
a fallacy but it used to be at least
from my vantage point that journalists
could like
weigh different competing considerations
in the interest of at least projecting
impartiality right and rationality now
they don't even care to pretend to do
that
they're on an ideologically zealous
mission and they're
they're proud of it and they try to
ostracize anybody who expresses
apprehension about
the need to see that as like the driving
impetus for what you're doing
they're growing that was part of the
reason why i went on my nationwide trip
uh because everything
yeah even if they weren't lying there
was there was
i don't know how many of them actively
lie that probably does happen i i
actually certainly don't know a lot but
the bigger problem in terms of why i was
motivated to do that was because they
were omitting
it was a lie by omission like these were
the biggest
most pervasive most widespread most
damaging riots
since at least the 1960s let's set this
up real quick so for those that aren't
familiar
uh michael you went on this trip around
the country to
all these different big cities small
towns to actually learn about what the
riots had done
why you know why they were happening how
people felt about them you took photos
from all these different places
yeah i took photos videos it was very
simple straightforward stuff which i
if i was a full-time staffer at a major
journalism
journalism institution some of which are
very well resourced like the new york
times has a record number
of subscriptions they're in great
financial shape cnn all these other
outlets
they're you know riding the trump bubble
for all it's worth which is why i think
that they're like probably
secretly depressed that it could you
know that that that the gravy train
might be running out relatively soon
um but what i had what i did
there's zero reason why it couldn't have
been done on a much wider scale with
people who have
full crews which have you know full uh
resources behind them all i did was get
in my dumpy car
drive around you know go to chicago uh
go to
minneapolis where i spent the bulk of
the time seattle portland
when you went to these really small
towns and smaller places you know like
fort wayne indiana people had no idea
that there were even riots there i
didn't know
i'm a pretty avid consumer of news for
better or worse sometimes worse
but i would have thought i would have
heard that there were the biggest riots
in memory in fort wayne indiana if it
had just been kind of i don't know
normally reported it wasn't you had to
dig
deeply in like underneath the narrative
to figure out that that had happened i
only
only knew what happened because i
happened to be passing through fort
wayne indiana
and i looked it up and i went and saw
for myself and spoke to people
and there were just so many other
examples
of that and it was bewildering
as somebody who was had this
journalistic
motivation not that it's a virtue
necessarily to have a journalistic
motivation but that tends to be what
drives me to do stuff
like go to georgia for the election go
to these random places after riots
just so i can get a relatively robust
understanding of what's happening and
then convey it as fairly as possible
while also at times you know co-mingling
my personal views there's no
nothing wrong with that necessarily but
i was i was
talking to people at these places like
it's particularly in minneapolis this is
like a month or so after
the peak of the riots and it was like
all anybody wanted to talk about
you walked down certain blocks and you
saw
some of the photos it was like rubble it
was as though it was
you know uh serbia in the late 90s or
something the boarded up windows
the begging on the win on this with you
know buildings
yeah you know uh you know minority
businesses that had to be
shuttered never to return um and it was
just like okay so there's so much
material here that if
we had a media which was interested
in conveying the story it would have
been trivially easy to do
you could have found the bodega owner
who was an iranian
who whose store that i went to that was
totally boarded up
wrecked entire inventory stolen you
could have tracked down that guy
done a 60-minute style interview where
he reflects on what this means about
like
what the what the meaning of this is for
the american dream or something however
gauzy you want to make it you could have
done it
and it wasn't done because
the media was so ensconced in a certain
ideological perspective where
doing this they viewed we would either
be
in opposition to the tenets of the
protest movement
and or helped trump and both of those
were lines that no moral person could
have ever crossed in their
view i don't even think that the latter
rationale made sense i don't think it
necessarily did
help trump look at the results in
minnesota one thing that i was always
fighting about with my you know
right-wing followers who i appreciate to
some extent because you know i like to
have a variety of perspectives
in terms of people giving me feedback
one thing that i always got into fights
with them about was they were saying oh
the riots mean that trump is going to
win whatever states the riots take place
and i was like no
that's not the sense i'm getting when
i'm talking to people who actually
experience the riots
i don't think that they viewed trump as
a remedy to the riots
i mean trump lost minnesota by a much
greater margin than he did
in 2016. you would think it would have
been the opposite if
the prophecies of a trump
resurgence in those areas came to
fruition which it didn't
i think maybe if trump were a little bit
more politically a droid that was
possible well
that just didn't happen people who
people who fled probably voted for trump
i i get messages from tons of people who
say they used to live in minnesota and
they had to leave because the riots were
so bad
so they left the state entirely yeah
absolutely yep but why not move to
different parts
these are these are like i've probably
got five emails where they were like hey
each one let you know
i lived near on the outskirts of
minneapolis we left we went to my
family's place
things like that i mean i've gotten some
of those emails too but like five is not
that i mean the point is
most people can't leave they don't have
the resources that they can up and leave
whenever so you should see something so
you should see
something if what was being argued to me
constantly online about trump's
benefiting from these riots came to pass
which it didn't
now i mean there is again we talk about
this regional variability there is some
a little bit of a mixed back there
because if you look at kenosha kenosha
county wisconsin
that did trend slightly republican
this year but it didn't in in in
minnesota so it doesn't it's hard to
make a firm all-inclusive extrapolation
there as to what happened
but just going back to the the riots
hey look i almost feel as that's already
all gotten
completely memory hold i mean this was a
historic event it was a nationwide
convulsion it clearly had some impact on
the election results we can't it's hard
to say with certitude
in what direction but all anybody could
talk about was that you know there were
the response times for 9-1-1 had gone
down
in minneapolis i was talking to somalis
who
had to fend off white rioters coming up
to their apartment building and starting
to burn it down
while there were children inside and so
you know if you
if you go through something like that
clearly it has to have some influence
on your political perspective i don't
mean i don't think that necessarily
means you're going to vote for trump
but clearly that has to have some
indelible impact and it just hasn't been
explored
to anywhere near the extent that you
would expect if the media was just
motivated
by sheer information gathering if there
was a public service that they were
guided by
i was actually talking to tim earlier
about i think journalism kind of has
at least two facets and one is
investigation and one is
reporting and these modern media giants
have just taken on the reporting faster
now
they barely investigate anything it's
analysis and opinion
well that's that's the investment the
investigation is missing
for sure you get people like james
o'keefe and and i think
uh scanner you know they're focused on
investigation
but cnn is just they just report what
they've heard i don't even know
analysis it's analysis okay well i don't
even think that's recording i don't
think that analysis
and reporting are incompatible like i do
a lot of reporting and then i analyze it
yeah but i try to be honest i try to be
transparent
i not try to just be totally in hocked
to some kind of partisan
agenda whether it's promoting a blm
antifa protest or whatever
or promoting trump like i mean i want to
actually
to the best of my ability and still
confidence that what i'm saying is
truthful and i think that that that's
just not something that so many people
in the media
are interested in if foundationally what
their guidance guided by is due to their
immersion
in the social milieus where if they
stray
from the consensus as to
the virtue of something like the protest
movement or something like
the world historic danger of fascist
authoritarian blah blah trump
then they can incur serious professional
or social consequences
and that is such a corrupt dynamic and i
think that's why we need
some kind of new media culture to sprout
out of the ruins of what we've gone
through
for the past four years i don't think so
i think there are people who own who
they they want confirmation bias i think
there are people who are
totally aware of like let's say i have
someone on the show
and we get a leftist we'll get a certain
percentage of people who are angry
and i think many of these people are
angry that you even bothered to have
them on the show
yeah yeah they're like how dare you
bring this you know this leftist guy is
anybody angry about me so far can we
check that oh i mean probably
screw you that's the spirit but but
anyway the point is
i think some of these people know the
issue isn't that
we disagree with this person necessarily
it's that
the their ability to speak will
influence people
and by giving them air time in any
capacity you are
we've gotten that argument like we've
platformed people before and i'm like
dude i plow platform people it's like
the stupidest thing ever
like to argue like i shouldn't have a
conversation with somebody because i i
would like to have conversations with
somebody even if there wasn't cameras
on us you know like the conversation
we're having now would be great even if
we weren't filming it
but uh i do my best to
ignore any kind of pressure from
somebody who's going to get mad at me
because i might tell them the truth
so what ends up happening is certainly i
have my bias on my youtube channel i
clearly don't like democrats
and people will watch that and say tim's
lying on purpose
to throw red meat to a follower it's
like no no no you don't understand
i just make videos where i talk about
what i feel is important
and then people come to me i'm like i'm
sitting on a soapbox and i'm yelling
and they're walking up around me to hear
what i'm saying and i have my biases
the difference with these news
organizations is the editor says don't
write that you're going to offend our
audience
and then they choose to avoid certain
stories because they're worried about
losing percentages and like you have an
active business decision to do this
do you do you take any active steps to
kind of and i mentioned this at the very
beginning but sort of like to insulate
yourself from the temptation
of cognitive capture where the audience
even if it's subliminal even if you're
not actively conscious of it
does have an influence on you in terms
of what
analysis you put forward or what you
choose to do in terms of
topics i mean there's a whole because i
don't i i find myself
wondering if i'm captive to that i don't
think it's i don't think it's possible
to necessarily
uh cr like i don't think it's possible
right so
an explanation it's not possible to be
fully immune to that
but i think if you're cognizant of its
potential
to hamper your ability to be impartially
objective not that anybody has to be
totally objective on anything
but you should at least be aware that
there are these
pressures coming off and and
well so so there's counteract them if at
all possible
so uh i think it's about mental
fortitude
i think it's about your assuredness and
your confidence in yourself
my political opinions um have changed
very little
or i should say they changed very little
over the years right i think the one
position i've changed on
heavily is guns in january i straight up
said to the people when we were our
house in new jersey i was like i don't
want any guns in my house period
no you can't bring a gun in my house i
don't want guns and then the riots
happened
and then i was like well i'm gonna go
buy some guns now and then i did and now
i don't want anyone taking them from me
so i i'm looking at these policies and
my position on guns have has
dramatically changed
because they want to defund the police
then
the riots are made to they were they
were very very close to our suburbs in
the south in
the south philly area or the south
jersey area the philly suburbs and so
i'm like
okay i better have the ability to defend
myself not only that but death threats
and someone tried breaking in my house
my opinion changed but in terms of like
my positions that i've always held
i've never been the strongest like
political zealot but all still fairly
independent left-leaning
positions progressive taxes pro-choice
all that stuff
social justice in certain certain
capacities and
pretty much stays where it is i bill i i
give my opinions on what i think
and then probably based on what i
learned there will be some changes
but core principles tend to be very you
know
obstinate as it were but there are a lot
of people on social media who don't have
that
who just read the comments and then go
for it because they're like oh now i'm
getting attention
for the most part what i see is uh i'll
use david pakman as an example do you
know you know david peckman
yeah he did a video where he said here
are things that i can't talk about and i
tremendously respect him for doing this
video
he said whenever i talk about these
things i get attacked for bringing it up
and then he went through all of the
things where his audience was like how
dare you bring this up and like how dare
you talk about these things
and he just said it all and i'm like
there it is man that's what you that's
that's that that's great
news organizations i think this is the
difference what people need to realize
about say youtube
is that like when i make a video i'm
like here's what i think
i'm one guy i'm choosing to talk about
how i feel and i've always done that
and then over time i get like more
confident in how i talk and present
myself because my earlier videos i'm
like really quiet and like low energy
and i just slowly got better and more
comfortable at just talking but my ideas
are based upon the news that i'm reading
as it develops
when i worked for fusion which was abc
news univision they straight up said
like lie to the audience they didn't say
verbatim they said side with the
audience
you know and i asked if there's news
stories that would make our audience
upset we wouldn't report it they said
yeah i think that's fair
so when you have an editorial board or a
president or
you know financial department or
whatever and they're going to the
reporter and saying oh
yeah that one don't don't report that
because we're going to lose our audience
then you're looking at people actively
deciding to create a partisan space
to make money versus youtube which is a
bunch of random people who have thoughts
and opinions who post them on the
internet you know what i mean
not that they're yeah but you know the
the danger in in the youtube
freewheeling culture was that so often i
see
people who are untethered to any kind of
standard of factual
confirmation or veracity and they just
kind of riff and i could riff
if if i really wanted to and sometimes i
do but you know
okay so i worked for the young turks for
like a year and a half and there are
people affiliated with young turks so
you could go and look at what they said
like a year prior in terms of making a
prediction on something
and it just doesn't come to pass and
then they just pay no price for it i
mean they just keep plugging along
and just i know i i feel that would if
that would diminish my credibility if i
did that so like when i was talking
about the
when i would talk about the election
this year i would always try to be
pretty qualified i mean i always thought
that biden stood a strong chance of
winning more so than trump and i said
that publicly many times
but i was never going to say that biden
is going to win or trump
can't win because i don't have a crystal
ball
and you know what if i said something
like that and it turned out to be false
then that should detract from my
credibility i i don't necessarily agree
i don't necessarily agree and it's
probably because i'm biased in favor of
myself
but there's like so you don't think that
if you say that something has no chance
of happening and then it happens no no
no no no that should detract from your
credibility
i i agree i'm not saying you
specifically i'm saying anybody so so
with a platform
this guy well i'll tell you michael i do
have a crystal ball oh wow he literally
does
yeah figured something out while you
were talking that is the most that is
the most stunning plot twist of the
movie
okay okay so so if if the young turks
are reading an article
and they're going over some news story
where it's like you know donald trump
backflipped off the you know the white
house and it was perfect stunning
everyone and brave
and then they're like i think you know
here's what's going to happen next i
have no problem with that
if like if they're making predictions
based on the news they're reading right
then
some people are like i want to hear what
you think maybe you're going to be wrong
sure you know but if you're if you're
reading news and then speculating it's
just
people giving their thoughts and
opinions well i mean don't go to them
like don't go to the pollsters and think
they're going to be right every time if
they're wrong all the time
you know you know that that almost like
i think there's you can do analysis
where you have
forward-looking you know
projections about what they are made not
happen but then it veers into this like
uh
you know tarot card [ __ ] i'm not
i'm not you're saying i like i have this
unique insight into the nature of the
universe where i can tell you
that you know joe biden couldn't
possibly win the presidency it's just
like how the hell
what is that based upon that does
describe the young turks i'm just saying
like
so there there are people who try and
take clips from me and i'm not even
singling out the young turtles
they're just i'm just most familiar with
them because i happen to work this is
what this is what the
the grifters do so they put up a video
where it's me saying
i think trump is going to win in a
landslide and various various clips like
that
going back to like october of last year
when moody's analytics said trump was
going to win because the economy was
great
they then take that from a context at a
time when the economy was great trump
was doing well
put it up today saying look how stupid
and wrong he was
and then people say wow what a [ __ ] but
if they actually watched my videos they
would have seen in the past month or two
months i was saying
polls are saying joe biden's gonna win
and i don't know if i should trust the
polls because they were wrong to a tiny
degree
in you know 2016 they're not that wrong
people people
overestimate how wrong they uh the
national polls weren't that wrong there
was a lot of state-based error which was
more consequential for the electoral
college obviously and so it was like a
two-point error among like non-college
educated whites
and my position was i don't know what's
going to happen but i think the polls
are going to be wrong i don't think you
can count trump out
and so that was my official position
based on the information presented in
the context of the election as it stands
right now
they go back and pull clips from when we
had mass rioting
and you know trump saying law and order
and me saying i think people are going
to recoil against this because i'm
getting phone calls
and they're saying you know i'm voting
for trump i know a ton of people in
chicago
die hard lifelong liberal democrat total
republicans now but see that's where i
would have
strove to be aware of my confirmation
bias because i could have these i mean i
i could come to a similar conclusion
based on the feedback i was getting
when i was traveling around the country
but i wouldn't have known that that was
not
statistically representative necessarily
of voting outcomes right so
you know i i just feel that if somebody
pulled the regardless of what the
circumstances were brothers if there
were riots regardless if it was
pre-coped
if somebody could find a clip of me
saying that
i know trump is going to win and then he
doesn't win
then i think that probably wouldn't
detract from my credibility and should
and you know maybe for sure certain
people are of a different mindset
i feel like i'm a little bit more
journalistic by nature than than others
again i'm not saying you or or anybody
in particular
but that that's an issue that i have
when i look on on youtube and
you know people can just bs constantly
and then they pay no reputational
consequences if they're bsing is just
proof
devastatingly wrong because they have
the audience or they could just keep
going
definitely people want the comforting
lies they don't want the truth i think
you're
um definitely more of an investigator an
investigative journalist than most
of the journalists in modern culture and
a lot of times
analysis journalism well the fact that
you drove across the country and didn't
know what you were going to find and
were willing to accept the results like
cnn doesn't want them to investigate
doesn't want their
rights because if they find things that
defy the narrative and will lose the
money i mean
i have done what you might call
investigative reporting but it's not
like my singular focus where i'm not
like getting
national security documents linked to me
or something right i just tried to be as
consistent
and logical as i possibly can not to do
my own horror i don't think i have a
horn to tute
necessarily but i try to apply that
analytically
so that i'm filtering my reportage in a
way that is
best reflective of the truth it doesn't
even actually have to entail
investigative reporting i mean if you
want to call just driving around the
country and talk to people and looking
at the fallout places doing interviews
and stuff investigative
i guess it maybe is in a way but really
it's it's it's pretty straightforward
um and so you know when i i i think
there's a lot of problems with legacy
media i mean that
new york time that new york article on
um new york times was
so embarrassing yeah and by the way
barry weiss got
totally uh destroyed
by her colleagues for making the exact
same observations as were in that
new york new york magazine article so
she was proven exactly right
whether or not you agree with everything
barry white says i don't but clearly her
analysis of the institutional dynamics
of the new york times were on target but
again the people who attacked her are
never going to pay
any reputational price i mean a constant
recurring problem in the media and this
i think applies to both the legacy media
and the alt media youtube media whatever
is that there's just never a price that
needs to be paid when people get stuff
so flagrantly
right you'll get hilariously wrong i
mean i was fighting with leftists in
march
who were saying there is no chance that
biden could win i was like what right
how do you know that
how are you so certain of that it's not
about predictions it's about facts in my
opinion
it's it's it's about an analytical
extrapolations that have no bearing on
reality
the way it doesn't matter because it
gets you the engagement that you want
and then you could parlay that into a
bigger audience the bigger issue i have
the issue i have that i think is more
pressing is when you have
new york times writers who constantly
put out bunk garbage
and they have no reputational you know
sure penance or whatever and they get
added
that russia yeah i mean they they were
the absolute
the new york times won a pulitzer prize
did they win more than one
further rusher reporting in 2017
and i wouldn't say it was fake
in that like that what they were
reporting on was just fabricated but the
premise
the premise upon which the reporting was
based was entirely
well erroneous so like why would you
have again shouldn't you
so what what i recommended when those
pulitzer prizes came out was either
throw them in the dumpster give them
back or abolish the pulitzer prize
writ large because it's meaningless now
the way i describe it is
people were like well the reporting was
sound and i'm like listen if i hire like
a
like a a groundskeeper or whatever for
my house like someone you know
lawn care guys and they come over and i
say i need you to mow my lawn and say
you got it
and then an hour later i come outside
and my neighbor's lawn is mowed
perfectly
and they like they did the wrong lawn
i'm not you want to give an award for
that it's like great they did the work i
get it but that's not what they were
supposed to be doing it's not
the work that needed to be done if if
what you're reporting on
isn't literally fabricated but
nonetheless it's so
directionally off course that what
you're doing in effect is misleading
the reader then you're doing it wrong
look at this way it's like a race a
marathon starts and one guy runs 26
miles
the other direction and they're like
well let's give him an award anyway like
he did run
and it's even worse because they're
getting paid like they'll make an
article that's erroneous and they'll get
ad massive ad revenue because it's a
shock article and then they'll print a
retraction and get ad revenue for the
retraction
so there's something severely wrong with
that function
maybe that you would sue that they would
actually it would put them out of
business that's the problem is they'd be
afraid to even report on anything
because if they get it wrong they lose
no the advertiser is looking for
eyeballs so these news organizations are
like not super worried that's fascist i
mean i think that's when corporation
starts to implement in like institute
our government
when when you can go in and write
political articles that are not bound in
fact when you can write
that somewhere there may be a video of
donald trump on an elevator
what he's doing we don't know who he's
with we're not sure does the video exist
we don't know either but some say it
might
huffington post wrote that article and
they got clicks they made money off that
could you imagine you wake up one day
and your editor's like i need a story
about donald trump and you're like
nothing happened just make it up donald
trump may have been an elevator i guess
no one knows if he was or why when
you've been on the receiving end of
journalists just
straight up making stuff up about you on
the internet oh yes
with you have no recourse i don't know
if you've experienced this or
not but i have and like i'm not even
that big of a target necessarily i mean
i guess some people are
vaguely aware of me but if they could do
that to me then who's to say who they
could do it to
and i think obviously social media so
exacerbates these dynamics it's
and that's third you can't even compare
it to a past era you know but
one reason for pessimism about this
election and i didn't
vote for trump i didn't vote for biden i
just left my ballot blank and voted for
marijuana closation and
nice new jersey which did pass
thankfully cool as somebody who
had to you know sneak into in the woods
as a teenager to indulge
in that i kind of felt like it was my
cosmic obligation to vote in favor of
legalizing finally in new jersey but
anyway um
one reason to be pessimistic about this
election income outcome
is and this isn't this is an argument
for trump per se
but it is a recognition that all the
tactics
that were used to undermine trump are
now going to be viewed as vindicated
yeah and they're going to be more kind
of enshrined in the fabric of
american political and cultural life
such that
you know we have this precedent now that
somebody like
trump is not going to be allowed to
happen again because you know they
have the security state machinations you
could have the total discarding by the
media of the principles
that they had previously worked on the
basis of
before but then when you have somebody
who's viewed as such this such a mortal
existential threat dial goes out the
window
um you have just
this constant resistance
where the election in 2016 was they did
try to delegitimize it
by automatically launching the quote
resistance with the hashtag
and seeing that through until it
culminated in trump's
impeachment so all those tactics i think
were done for the singular purpose
primarily uh undermining hobbling and
ultimately defeating trump
and if that's proven to have worked
that's really i'm going to sign
for the nature of american democracy
i'm not saying that trump has been a
perfect emblem of democracy and all that
he's done
but you know i think that the media is
so blinkered
in their inability to recognize that the
oppositional tactics employed
to degrade trump have really
damning long-term implications in their
own right thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you